All right.
So today we're going to talk about
everything is illuminated and Eli has
actually agreed to stand next to me
for the whole lecture and translate my
lecture into Ukrainian
dialect. Thank you, Eli.
I'll call you up in a minute
for anyone visiting the class today,
what we are doing is talking
about a Jonathan Safran fours.
Everything is illuminated.
This book was chosen by the class
as the last book of the syllabus.
And Eli here gave a wonderful
presentation, a reading
from it in a very, uh,
funny Ukrainian accent. Um, and I
think that's why everybody chosen. Um,
God knows if there would be another
reason. No, just kidding. Um,
now when you meet a new novel,
when you meet a new novel, uh, there
are various things you need to do, uh,
after you've decided whether
you like it or not. If that is,
if you're either a professor in an English
class having to teach it or you are a
student having to talk about it or
write about it in your papers. Uh,
beyond that,
even beyond vocational necessity,
there is the desire.
Uh,
I hope that many people have to understand
how new work fits into the body of
existing literature.
And especially,
I think that's the case when an author
is as openly ambitious as Jonathan Safran
Foer is.
It is very clear the minute you open
this up and you start reading a,
that four is aiming at a conversation
with literature that has proceeded him.
Uh, it's also clear from
his interviews and, uh,
I was particularly struck by something
he said in an interview about his second
novel, um, extremely loud and incredibly
close, which is about nine 11.
And I'll, I'll say a little bit more
about that novel, which I haven't read,
but I've read enough reviews of it,
uh, to know a few facts about it,
which I think are relevant to
this novel. Um, he said about it,
he was asked by an interviewer,
well,
doesn't it seem risky
to take on nine 11 as a,
as a subject? And he said, well,
what seems risky to me is not taking
on the important subjects of your time.
That seems like the risk for a writer.
And he says in another place,
you know,
you have to justify the fact that you're
sitting alone in a room writing all
day. What you do has to
be somehow world changing.
So, uh, for a 20 something
year old writer, this is a,
a heavy task and I think you
can feel the heaviness of it in,
in the novel,
um,
partly in its formal ambition and
partly in the subjects that, uh,
it takes on. It doesn't take on nine 11,
uh, but it does take on the Holocaust.
So I will have a whole argument about
that aspect of the novel and how it fits
into literature of the post 45
period because, uh, lucky you,
I happen to have written
a book on this. Uh, I'm,
Vic came out in 2000 to three,
uh, about genocide and literature.
So this is actually perfect novel for
me to lecture on. Uh, in that respect,
when you first meet a novel of
this kind with these ambitions,
there are certain things that you do.
And for me,
those things include noticing just about
everything I possibly can about the
novel and then thinking about what
other things that I've read seem to be
speaking to it or it seems to
be speaking to those things. Um,
now I promised that I would not
conduct this entire lecture in Q and a,
but I did not promise that I wouldn't
ask any questions. So here goes, um,
what novels seem related to this
novel from our syllabus to you?
Well, you can see, you can go
outside our syllabus. That's okay.
Did you have another
idea? Yes. Yes. That's,
that's certainly in dialogue
with this novel. Yes.
And four talks about that as a novel
that really was important to him. Okay.
What else? What from our syllabus
seems to be related to this novel.
Okay.
You've never seen
anything like this before?
Yes.
Lolita. Why? What in Lily too.
Okay. Yes. Some of that
humor. Yes. What else?
What else from our syllabus? Yes. Also.
Oh, I was going to get shuffled on Lolita.
Yes, sure. Experiment. Did the 80 fine.
Speeding through the voice over
character. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah.
Inhabiting a voice that seems very foreign
to the writer.
Yes.
What else?
Yes. All right. Okay.
Yes. And what was it about Barth
that you think for learned from,
I think I've writing about writing.
Yes.
Yeah, absolutely. Yup.
Definitely. What else?
Roth.
Did anyone not see Rothan
this novel. Okay. Um,
Roth is certainly here. Um,
pension is very strongly here.
If you think about the episodes in
crying of lot 49 with the paranoids,
those all those funny
jokes and their songs, uh,
far learned a lot from pension
and even more from pensions,
other novels. Gravity's rainbow
I think particularly. Um,
then from crying flop 49,
which doesn't because of its leg,
doesn't quite go to the operatic
playful lengths that a pension,
longer pension novel can go to.
Um,
pigeon is also very interested
in the 18th century.
And so that interest is something
that for our shares in this novel,
um,
for is someone who learned a lot from
the group of writers that we would call
postmodernist and that I
would call late modernist. Um,
he learned to be very self conscious about
his language and to make that evident
on the surface of the novel.
He also learned though from
Toni Morrison come on in.
He learned from Tony
Morrison in particular,
I think he learned the value
of time travel in an novel.
This was something that I brought up with
respect to Edward P. Jones as well. Um,
but it's certainly here and
there's one very, very clear,
um,
reference to two Morrison.
This is on page 51 when,
when they're talking, he's
talking about the name of the,
of the shuttle
and how it was,
how it was called. Now, uh, my,
my Ukrainian is not very premium,
so I will butcher this name.
Of course,
no one in some, uh, suffuse
called, it's called, it's a Fucca
until it had such a disagree,
uh, until it had such a
disagreeable official name,
no one felt the need to call it anything.
But now there was that,
there was an offense that the shuttle
should be called that shitheads namesake.
The citizens had to,
had to a name not to go buy some,
even called the Shtetl,
not see a sofa and would continue to do
a to even after the new name was chosen.
Um,
in Song of Solomon written in 1979,
I think,
um,
Toni Morrison has a street that's called
not doctor street because it was called,
uh, it was given an official name at
odds with what the black community, uh,
called it. Um, and so they call
it head called it doctor street.
The town Christen did something else,
I think main street or something.
And so then they called it
not doctor street. So this,
this little teeny piece is
lifted directly from Morrison.
You can see her footprints
on here in that sense.
Tony Morrison was of course a teacher,
uh,
at Princeton when four was there.
I don't know if he took courses with her.
He certainly studied with
Joyce, Carol Oates. Um,
but Morrison was around and I'm
sure he has read that novel.
It would be surprising
to me if he has not. Um,
so the other thing that he takes from
Morrison is that sense of collective
history,
that history is something passed down
in oral tradition in an intensely verbal
culture.
So the Jewish shtetl culture that far
imagines and the black community that
Morrison imagines are both
intensely verbal cultures.
Now the Jewish community of forest novel
is also intensely literary in the sense
of literate. They write
everything down also. Um,
so that's a slight difference
between Morrison's vision and force.
I want to go into some detail about
what I think for has learned from Roth
because Roth is the person I see
most strongly behind his writing.
We didn't see the playful metaphysical
side of Roth very much in the human
stain.
Roths work is straddling both sides of
that line between realism and very hyper
metaphysics banality. So some of
his novels have alternate endings.
Um, he has several novels
that, uh, feature Philip Roth.
So four takes the, um,
conceit of naming himself,
uh, in naming character after
himself directly from Roth.
So there are ways that he is
on the surface sighting Roth,
but there's a more profound way
that he's working in Ross terrain.
And that is in the terrain of desire.
So thinking back to Roths,
first novel Portnoy's complaint,
which is all about masturbation,
Alex Portnoy's masturbation,
we see that he's taken the name
Alex, uh, Alexander Portnoy.
Alex appears in this novel as well.
And then we have saffron who
is this a sort of love machine.
So he is a double of,
um,
Alex Portnoy with a difference though.
So instead of masturbation,
it's sex with the needy,
essentially sex with the love
starved virgins, older women,
a widows,
et cetera.
So the immediate difference that four
is pointing to is the difference between
something like solipsism or narcissism,
desire as the fuel for that narcissism
versus desire as the fuel for community
and connection.
This is not without trouble though.
And it's the trouble that interests me.
And that I think he takes from Roth.
And that's the impossibility of ever
actually making that connection of it ever
finally coming home. And you see that, uh,
in the story of saffron,
just in the fact that by the time he
finally gets married and finally has a
proper orgasm,
what he falls in love with as that
at that moment is not his wife,
but the baby that he is in
gendering in that moment.
And of course it's a baby, uh,
that is, doesn't even exist yet.
So the very absence at
the heart of desire,
the blankness or the impossibility is
demonstrated even in those moments of
overwhelming connection.
Okay.
And I think it's telling that for imagined
sexual energy as light rather than
some other kind of a phenomenon.
So everything is illuminated.
Remember,
there's that image of the world
being lit up by people making love,
that it actually generates light
that you can see from space.
It's not a concrete in gendering act.
Even when it is,
it creates something else.
And that's something else seems
to be related to knowledge.
How can you know your past?
This is a problem in the novel and
it's a feature of the quest element.
And I'll say more about that in my
second lecture on the novel. Um,
but I think it has to do with a vague
understanding that is imagined to
illuminate the world
as a result of desires,
fulfillment.
We're almost fulfillment.
But that theme of sex and desire is
abstracted into lots of other forms.
And the couple that I want to look at,
um,
one is a sort of religious,
this is on one 40.
Yeah.
Here we're learning about the
veneration of broads husband,
the Kulchar who is then
bronzed and made into a, uh,
a statue in the town after he dies.
I'm still with the saw blade
embedded in his head. Um,
and this is at the bottom of one 40.
Yeah.
Those who prayed came to believe less
and less in the god of their creation and
more and more in their belief, the
unmarried kissed the dials, battered lips,
although they were not faithful
to their god, but to the kiss,
they were kissing themselves.
And when the bride knelt,
it was not the God they believed in.
It was the Neal,
not the God's bronze knees,
but their own bruised ones.
This little moment of reflection on
religious ritual or quasi religious ritual
is related to some,
um,
things that I want to say about the
role of Judaism in my next lecture.
But as a practice,
it is a practice of negativity,
of acknowledging the impossibility
of connection to that God and the
impossibility of
fulfillment from that God.
But nevertheless,
it is committed to the fulfillment of
the effort to make that connection.
So it's belief in belief.
And in fact,
the book that I'm writing right
now is all about belief and belief.
And so this confirms my sense that this
is an important way of imagining how
belief works in the
current moment. Uh, you,
you believe in the act of belief.
So that's one kind of negativity.
Then there's a visual image
that we get over and over again,
and that's of the whole,
the empty hole.
There are a couple of
examples here. Um, on one 35,
this is after broad and the Colker have
separated themselves with a wall because
the coker keeps beating
her up. He's uh, uh,
deranged in part part saying
part d arranged by his,
a saw blade embedded in his head.
And so they have this whole,
between them, uh, through
which they can communicate.
But the wall protects
broad from his rages.
So he won't beat her up. They lived, this
is only 35. They lived with the whole,
the absence that defined,
it became a presence that defined them.
Life was a small negative space
cut out of the eternal solidity.
And for the first time it felt precious.
Not like all of the words
that had come to me,
nothing but like the last
breath of a drowning victim.
So here were offered two
versions of negativity.
One is all the words that had come to me,
nothing.
And the other is this physical emptiness,
the hole.
So the words that mean nothing.
Our an emptiness that ar is
a frustrating a blockage,
but the emptiness that is the space,
the visual space comes to be a space
of imagination that gets filled with
imagination.
So they see each other from a distance
for the first time and are overwhelmed by
the connection that can
then be formed between them.
So it's the very absence of the physical
presence ones, distance from it.
That becomes the
fulfillment for this couple.
Yeah.
So this,
I hope you can see the
structural similarity or the
logical similarity between
believing in belief
and were told of broad.
Remember also on page 83
that she was constitutionally
unable to love anyone.
Uh, this is at the top of 83 when
she said, father, I love you.
She was neither naive nor dishonest,
but the opposite.
She was wise and truthful enough to lie.
They reciprocated the great and saving
lie that our love for things is greater
than our love for our love,
for things willfully playing the parts
they wrote for themselves, willfully,
fully creating and believing
fictions necessary for life.
So if this is the lie that our love for
things is greater than our love for our
love for things,
the truth is that our love for our love
is greater than our love for actual
things or actual persons.
It's the same structure
as the belief in belief.
Of course,
that
story of broad and her father telling
each other stories both about their love
for each other.
And in her father's case,
your uncle's case about her mother,
her fictional mother who
he says died before. Uh,
she was, uh, old enough to remember her.
All the stories that your uncle makes
up become the fullness of his life with
broad.
So they replace the loss of his
first wife who abandoned him.
And so this gives fiction a very
powerful brief in the world.
Yeah.
This is not unlike the structure that
I was pointing out in the human stain
where the blankness of Coleman and Fanya
allows Nathan to re inhabit life by
imagining onto them all the
dynamics of their desire,
all the facts of their life,
all the details of their biography.
So likewise for uses blankness as a
way of pumping up the power of fiction.
It plays this role despite the threat.
It will always pose to
fiction that you get here,
uh, in or on that little, um,
in that little passage I just
quoted before about the, not the,
the nothingness of words.
So the nothingness that gives fiction,
it's blank space to
inhabit also can seep into.
And in fact a words as in the
repetition of a word like, um,
Malcovich
it is an infection that bothered
critics about this novel.
They felt that the postmodern play of
the novel was essentially trivial because
these kinds of play had been
conducted in novels 30 years,
40 years before,
and many more than that.
If you count Tristram Shandy
in the 18th century. Um,
but took powerful hold in
American fiction in the 60s,
they felt that far was simply taking out
those tools and deploying them again,
but not for any new sort of payoff.
So fiction, some critics were
frustrated with this. Now,
this brings me to a second kind of context
that I would bring to this novel, uh,
or I do bring to this novel.
As I think about it. In 2001,
Jonathan Franzen's novel, the
correction won the national book award.
The corrections attempted
to make a marriage between
the postmodern novel as he
understood it,
the novel filled with
those kinds of verbal play
and Franzen,
uh,
modeled his novel on
William goddesses novel,
the recognitions,
which is about an art forger.
It's about 900 pages of
incredibly experimental pros.
Um,
it's extremely hard to read,
but for friends in that novel had enough
in it of character development and
human investment to go along with its
verbal playfulness that it made him want
to keep reading it.
So in Omaj to that novel,
he called his novel the corrections
and tried to give us a story where the
verbal play would not drain
the sentiment from the novel.
So he described it as the social novel
coming to meet the postmodern novel.
He announced this to great
fanfare in an essay. Uh,
and of course the novel then became
famous and he became infamous when he was
invited by Oprah to go on Oprah's book
club with the corrections and he refused.
It was quite a, uh, a scandal
in the literary world.
And then he tried to go back
on it and say, oh, okay, Oprah.
I really wasn't being a snob all come
on your show. But then she was like, no,
sorry, we're scheduled
for that week now. Um,
it was really a, uh, a
mistake on Franzen's part,
but it also demonstrated
his own ambivalence about
the very project he had set
out to accomplish,
which is to make a novel that people
really want to read that has some
sentimental purchase on you that has
characters you could care about as well as
being extremely ambitious in this way,
in this formal way.
Now that novel,
the way it tried to get sentiment and
verbal play to line up was in part by
making one of the central
characters and Alzheimer's patient.
So it's about a man,
it's about a family in Midwestern family.
And the two parents gets extended
treatment in the novel as do the three
children in the grown children in the
family. And the father has Alzheimer's.
And so there's a very
pinching esque scene. When,
uh, his actually his, his, uh,
shit starts talking to him and
this is taken right out of, uh,
gravity's rainbow. There's a scene very
similar to this in gravity's rainbow,
so France and tried to make that
poignant by making it something that the
modernist tried to do,
which is the representation of the actual
workings of a human mind in a daily
situation.
And the terror of it for that character.
I thought when I read the novel
came across quite powerfully.
So for me in part it worked
far is doing something that is related.
He is trying to have both
sentiment and formal play.
How many of you felt for these characters,
how many of you felt that they were
really inaccessible to you? Flat, uh,
on emotionally interesting
to you? Okay. Just one.
So he, I think he succeeded, uh,
probably two greater degree.
If you read the critics and you can read
that in this incredibly bulked up blurb
section, uh, in the
packaging of this novel. Um,
a lot of critics did really like
this novel and I think that's why
that it for most readers,
he did succeed.
Now I have a things to say
about that, but in a minute, uh,
I want to say that there is another
kind of context that I think you could
attend to productively.
And that is the quality of
this novel as a campus novel.
Now that's probably not exactly what
you were thinking of when you read this
novel. It's a canvas novel
because it was written on a campus
and it's also a campus novel because it
is in part a coming of age novel about
someone who goes from needing a lot of
help with his writing to kind of writing
on his own.
Yeah.
So what you see is the displacement of
a narrative that looks very much like
fours development or you would imagine
the development of a writer and a writing
program at Princeton over time,
at first needing
suggestions from a mentor.
And a lot of the way that we
come to know the character,
Jonathan Safran Foer in the beginning
through Alex's letters has to do with
things that he has said to Alex about
how to write suggestions he's made.
So Jonathan Safran Foer remains as a
sort of shadowy presence for much of this
novel.
But we see his wise sayings
to Alex about writing.
It's an interesting inversion of the
situation that the author was in fact in,
he was in the class taking the class,
not teaching the class when
he was an undergraduate.
And this was written when he was,
I think it was published when he was 21
the bar is not high, don't
know. The bar is very high.
Let me say that the bar is very high,
but don't worry. Um, life is long.
You have plenty of time.
Um,
okay.
This is not just about
Jonathan Safran Foer,
the man and his particular biography of
being a student in the writing program
at Princeton.
It is also about a,
an institutional history of writing in
the second half of the 20th century.
If you remember way back when,
when I lectured on Flannery O'connor,
I mentioned to you a critic
named Mark Mcgill at Ucla who uh,
is writing a book called the program
era or has written, I think it's,
it should be out very soon,
called the program era.
And it's an analysis of
how writing programs leave
their mark on the fiction of
the last 50 years.
Because what's particularly striking
and knew about writing in this period is
that a lot of it happens on campuses and
a lot of authors are writing for campus
audiences.
So far is novel,
is a version of that kind of fiction.
And we can read it that way,
I think quite easily.
It fits in that story that Mark McGrail
tells about the development of this
period.
So just as when I read it,
I see that notation about belief
and belief and the love of love,
and it fits into a story that I'm telling
about the evolution of religion and
literature in this period.
So you can ally it to other arguments
that are made about the period two and
that help you to see why certain things
might be in the novel and what kind of
work they do there.
And finally,
there's a last content context that I um,
saw pointed out,
I think it was in the review in the
nation and that's of trips of Americans to
post communist Europe and
post communist Russia.
Apparently there is a whole spate of
novels that came out right about the same
time where Americans almost invariably
young men went to the former Soviet
republics and had coming
of age experiences.
So this certainly fits that genre.
I don't personally have
a lot to say about that.
I think it's interesting to see it as
being aligned with a group of novels that
do that. Um, it doesn't for me
provide any particular onsite,
but that's not because it's
because it wouldn't, it just
happens that I'm not, uh,
that didn't strike a chord with me or
lead me to other points of analysis.
This is another point that I want you to
take away from my engagement with this
novel that is that no matter what
context can be brought to it,
you as a reader bring
your own particular one,
your own particular set of knowledge,
your own particular training,
your own life experience.
So we're getting to the end
of the course and in a way,
uh, you have now the opportunity
to approach these novels,
any new novel that's written with several
kinds of stories about the period in
your mind because now you have read,
I hope you've read many
novels in this period
and you can see where the connections are.
So you're starting to draw those.
You'll need to do that on the exam.
But far more importantly,
I hope that you will continue to do it
when you read on your own outside of
class,
a lot of you are seniors.
You may not have a lot of time after
you leave school to read novels.
When you do,
I hope it will be part of your pleasure
to approach them with a sense of
empowerment that you can know where
they fit in the history of the art form.
They're engaging apart from your own
pleasure in reading them, which will,
I'm sure be the primary reason
you'd pick up a novel to read it.
But there is that intellectual
pleasure that you now can have.
I went to, to encourage you
to feel that you can do that.
It doesn't mean that it will
always produce insight for you.
So I've been thinking about this
novel for approximately two weeks.
Most novels that I lecture to you about,
I've been thinking about
for at least two years.
Okay.
Your insights over time change and you
notice different things and it's nice to
allow time for that.
And that's the value of
rereading in a few years,
what you read before as a student.
So I hope you'll maybe return to some
of these novels as well. Now, look,
that was my little digression about after
college reading or an outside of the
class reading, but let me return
to this question of sentiment.
Yeah,
far wants it both ways.
And one of the ways he has it both
ways is by internalizing in the novel a
reader figure who is our double.
There's actually a couple of, uh,
there are actually three doubles for us,
at least.
One is Alex who is reading Johnathan's
story as he sends it to him,
embedding a critical reader within
the novel as we've seen with Barth
and in pension where Eto was,
that double allows a certain
set of metta fictional tricks.
One of the most reliable functions for
that internalized reader is to cue you,
me,
the actual human readers to
notice or feel certain things.
Or if you are a off to be
misled in certain ways.
Think of the prologue from John Ray Jr,
which misleads us in reading that novel.
He's our double,
but he's there to trick us.
I don't think that Alex is here to trick
us and just to note how he cues us.
Let's look on one 40,
uh,
two
and three.
This is um,
one of the letters where the Alex is
less busy with self presentation by this
point in the novel and he's really
responding to what Jonathan has sent him.
This is in the middle of one 43 those
things that you wrote in your letter about
your grandmother made me remember how
you told me on Augustine steps about when
you would sit under her dress and how
that presented you. Safety and peace.
I must confess that I became melancholy
then and still am melancholy.
I was also very moved.
Is this how you use it by what you wrote
about how impossible it must've been
for your grandmother to be a mother
without a husband is amazing. Yes.
How your grandma father survived so much
only to die when he came to America.
It is as if after surviving so much,
there was no longer a reason to survive.
When you wrote about the early
death of your grandfather,
it helped me to understand in some manners
the melancholy that grandfather has
felt since grandmother died and not
only because they both died from cancer.
I do not know your mother of course,
but I know you and I can tell you that
your grandfather would have been so,
so proud.
It is my hope that I will be a person
that grandmother would have been so,
so proud of.
We're being cued to be moved to be moved
by the story in these particular ways
to take his reflections
on his grandmother,
which are indeed very lovely
and to be moved by them.
But one reservation I guess I have about
the success of this move is just it's
baldness.
I guess I'm being told that I
should be moved by these passages.
Okay.
There are also moments
when we get reflections
that seam.
Okay.
Like they would never stand if they
were not embedded in Alex's voice.
And this is on 69 68 69 this is Alex
talking about how he came upon
little Igor, his brother crying.
I knew why he was a
little less than crying.
I knew very well and I wanted to go to
him and tell him that I had a little less
than cried too,
just like him.
And that no matter how much it seemed
like he would never grow up to be a
premium person like me with many girls
and so many famous places to go, he would.
He would be exactly like me
and look at me a little Igor.
The bruises go away and so does how
you hate and so does the feeling that
everything you receive in
life is something you have
earned and then I'm going
to skip down so he starts to laugh then
at his brother and he's not quite sure
why he's laughing.
I attempted to rise that
I could walk to my room,
but I was afraid that it would be
too difficult to control my laughing.
I remained there for many,
many minutes.
My brother persevered to
a little less than cry,
which made my silent laughing even more.
I am able to understand now that it was
the same laugh I had in the restaurant
and loads the laugh that had the same
darkness as grandfather's laugh and the
heroes laugh.
I ask leniency for writing this.
Perhaps I will remove it before I
post this part to you. I am sorry.
As for Sammy Davis Junior, junior, she
did not eat her piece of the potato.
Those reflections on laughing and crying.
I think they might sound quite modeling
if they were not in Alex's voice.
That a writer needs to judge
very carefully whether to
reflect in those direct
ways about big themes like laughter
and crying or how you hate.
So these are the topics that we'll be a
pitfall for any new writers sitting down
to say, I am going to write
about love. I used to,
I used to teach creative writing
and one of the, um, one of,
one of the exercises that I did was I
would sit my students down and I would
say, okay, we're going to have a
little in class writing today. Um,
here's some topics that I want you
to write about just for 10 minutes.
And I would give them love your childhood.
Um,
what else? Death. Uh,
can't remember what else.
And so then they'd very earnestly
do it. And then I'd say, okay,
now, now I want you to, uh,
take your paper and I want
you to underline every
single cliche that you wrote.
And they would come up with papers full
of cliches and it was a little exercise
just to get them to understand
that choosing a topic, uh,
can get you into trouble if
you choose a very abstract,
big important question.
Of course we want books that move us
and tell us about death and love and
separation and desire.
But how do you get there and how
do you talk about those things?
So I think that for has,
um,
taken a risk of some of the sort here
he can do it because it's in Alex's
voice is the distance achieved the self
distancing achieved by inhabiting a
foreign voice with its little funny jokes
that come up because of
its incorrect usages.
Is that enough
to prevent sentimentality
rather than Centamin?
Is it powerful enough language in the
abstract that it moves us as a discourse
on laughter and loving is the detail
of Little Igor and Alex's love for him
enough? Now remember, we know
nothing about Igor as a character,
his brother as a character.
Do we feel that the relationship between
the two is earned for us as readers?
Maybe we do.
Sometimes I did.
Other Times I didn't.
So this is something that
I'm still thinking about.
Does it succeed at what
Franzen too was trying to do,
which is to infuse intellectual
wordplay with human resonance?
Does it succeed?
If you look at the
dedication to the novel,
I think you learned something too.
This is under the acknowledgements.
Did anybody read this?
Yeah,
these are the acknowledgements at
least once every day since I met her,
I have felt blessed to know Nicole Roggie.
She inspires me not only to
try to write more ambitiously,
but to smile more widely and have
a fuller, better heart. I am so,
so grateful and you hear
that. So, so again, uh,
from the passage I just read
and it is my pleasure and honor to think
of the wonderful people at Ho Houghton
Mifflin as family,
so on and so on,
whose advice in literature and life
seems always to boil down to feel more,
which is always the best advice.
So feeling is very much on the
surface of the effort here.
What would it mean to read
this as a sentimental novel?
Does the playful treatment of Shtetl
life disable our connection with those
characters.
One of the things that I think succeeds
wonderfully about this novel is broad as
a character.
I think you do want her to have a good
life as Alex does and you feel the
tragedy of the life she gets.
And I think you get that payoff
because she is developed,
she has time to develop in
the course of the story.
So for all its time travel back and forth
for all it's playfulness for all the
jokes and rifts broad has time to develop,
especially in relation to her
father and in relation to the coker,
her husband.
And we learn things that may
occur more complex over time.
And so when we finally learn what she
asked the coker to do after she was raped
and before she agreed to be his wife,
when we learned that,
and I won't reveal it cause I don't know
if you're all there yet, it gives us,
uh,
a much more complex version of what
she is as a person of who she is as a
person.
So I think he earns it with broad.
Yeah.
That to me is a kind of achievement
because of the role that riffing plays in
the development of that story.
Riffing on Jewish behavior in a novel
by a Jewish writer is certainly well
trodden ground Roth has been treading
that ground for many decades.
I think what four does that Roth didn't
do is fully identify with the community
in a convincing way
while he's doing it,
and this is related to what I will
say about his use of the Holocaust,
uh,
in my next lecture,
I'm going to stop there and I hope you
will be sure to finish the novel by,
by Wednesday.